I definitely dabbled in the ways of the
night I really got after it I mean I was
in a 12-year relationship and then I
just went ham yeah on the gash because
that was your high school sweetheart
right yes yeah yeah so after that I mean
it was weird cuz it was like right when
bumble and tinder was popping so like
that was all out there to use I had so
many resources and you know it's working
all these comedy clubs in the in New
York City and all over the country so
like you could just land in Denver
excuse me Oh semen and you just land in
Denver and then just start scrolling and
be like oh my man look at this and then
you're the guy at the comedy clubs he
already looked cool you're like hey I'm
performing here all weekend they're like
oh [ __ ] I know he's not a serial killer
he's here and you know it's better than
just being like hey I'm a loser will you
let me go down on you you know you have
a thing where you're a comedian so it
was pretty also I used to open for Amy
Schumer and that was like you know
10,000 screaming ladies and I can't bang
her so I got the run off what was the
most maybe in one night ah Jesus I feel
bad this is this is gonna get me in
trouble
but I don't know I had a I had a three
for a hat-trick in New York whoa woke up
at a girl's place bang met a girl for
lunch
bang I met a girl that night bang but
it's just you know those days are over
now I got a I got a hot lady of course
yes but yeah we had a we had a good run
but it just it does where it wears off
you know like after a while you're like
this is a lot of work my whole life was
you know juggling and texting and trying
to be funny with this wouldn't be
charming with that one and then put out
a fire over here and all that and it was
it's a lot of messaging that's a lot of
work yeah just going in somewhere then
you hit did you have a system for like
did you end up having like go-to women
every time you hit a certain City yeah
yeah roster yeah that was fun that was
fun and the ladies they're there they're
having a good time as well you know this
wasn't all just you know macho [ __ ]
this is like hey you're having fun I
don't [ __ ] shame I hope you don't [ __ ]
shame and
let's be grown-ups here and have a good
time uh genitalia wise so what is so
Craig Craig had his story of like this
she was like a playmate or whatever with
her friend and she one could like squirt
on demand and the other one could like
queef on demand Wow
so what a comedy duo well you know the
love-master
I guess so yeah got it so what is what
story does the love doctor have oh jeez
hey love the tape uh well I did a show
once in Florida this is years ago and I
got an uber ride home and uber was you
know it's like this milfy kind of 45
year old lady 40 year old lady and she
was like oh were you just on I was like
eh I was performing she was like I
wanted to go to the show but I couldn't
and I said well here come tomorrow I got
her some tickets ended up banging the
uber drivers she just got divorced and I
said I'm staying she knew where I was
staying because she dropped me off and I
said when you get off come by and I'll
get you off and did you say that
something like that yeah some horrible
line I was in the car with a bunch of
the comics so I was like doing it in
front of them which was weird but then
we got to the hotel I told her what room
I was in and like four hours later I was
laying in bed I'd taken a sleeping pill
which is always a bummer and then I
heard a knock and that was it so I had
to fight through the pill and go at it
how'd it go it was great it was great
victory float very Florida a lot of
crazy tats a lot of anal stuff
you name it took a shower it was wild
uber baby it's the end the untapped
dating app I guess uh yeah I mean it's a
lot of Middle Eastern men but if you can
find a blonde Florida mom I say go for
it
Wow yeah it was a fun night you're an
inspiration to us all mark I guess I got
a free ride after all five stars five
stars on the five stars it's an easy
joke we won't I know I don't want your
your lady to hear all this yeah so we'll
pivot a little bit because we can't
comedy is also a mistress Oh
like it Segway we call that in the biz
yeah Segway kids also a little vehicle
and when we're thinking of comedy being
the the devilís mister she is I know you
had the Comedy Central special came out
yes but you want it to be are you
pitched it to Netflix first or the
Netflix said no yes I used to just drink
a hundred beers I just drink a bunch of
beers all night I would just drink and
now I'm like oh that beer is this many
calorie it's like I hate them that guy
but you got to worry high breath